Let's see the solution for our instruction pipelining quiz.
We have a five-stage pipeline. Each stage takes one
clock cycle. We have ten instructions. If we do
instructions one at time with no pipelining, each instruction will
need to go through all five stages. Takes five
cycles to do that. And then the next instruction can
go, and takes five cycles to do that, and
so on. So we're going to have five cycles per instruction,
times ten instructions. It will be 50 cycles
until we are done. With pipelining, remember that
the first instruction will take five cycles to
go through but the next instruction will be
one cycle behind. So it will take one
cycle to get the next instruction, one cycle
to get the one after that, and so
on. So the remaining nine instructions finish every cycle.
Overall, it takes 14 cycles. As you can see again, we
have a significant speed-up from using pipelining. And just like with laundry,
don't forget that it takes some initial number of cycles to fill
the pipeline. Only then, we can get an instruction leaving every cycle.